how surprising would it be if the worker
that you scored from another company
polished and honored leaves your company
and turns out to be your biggest rival
sounds unreal doesn't it well that is
exactly what happened with steve jobs
and john scully it would appear that
after leading through some of its best
periods as it ushered the world into the
personal computer revolution apple's
ex-ceo is back with his own company and
products to rival the iphone will he be
successful let's find out
scully's smartphone sf1 and sj 1.5 after
his tenure at apple john scully has
started another technological venture
known as ob world phone so let's talk
about the amazing specs of john scully's
brand new handsets sf1 and the sj 1.5
the two smartphone models were announced
by the former apple ceo's company ob
world phone in august 2015 since its ob
world phone's objective to manufacture
premium quality phones to the developing
markets of countries like asia africa
and the middle east these sub 250
android devices sound promising when it
comes to low budget smartphones scully
described sf1 and sj 1.5 as two high
high-quality premium designed
smartphones priced at an exceptional
value to attracting discerning young
people in fast growth markets in asia
africa and the middle east let's talk
about the sf1 first this model is named
after the city of san francisco it's an
elegant fiberglass android with a sleek
metallic look moreover the sf1 has a
5-inch gorilla glass 4 display with a
fantastic resolution of 1920x1080
this economical phone also has dolby
audio with 7.1 channels of high fidelity
speakers pretty good so far right and
not just that but the 4g lte smartphone
is also outfitted with a snapdragon 615
processor and has the capacity for two
sim cards oh and there's good news for
people who love to take pictures because
the sf1 also has a 13 megapixel rear
camera powered by sony's imx 214 exmoor
sensor the camera also has an automatic
focus and it's embellished with geo
tagging touch focus face and smile
detection and 1080p video at 30 frames
per second the front doesn't disappoint
as well with a 5 megapixel camera and
led flash with a respectable 3 000
milliamps battery the sf1 smartphone is
a great device for anyone wishing to buy
a budget phone with awesome specs now
there are two variations for the sf1 one
variant will have two gigabytes of ram
and 16 gigabytes of internal storage
with a price tag of 199. while the other
one is equipped with three gigabytes of
ram and 32 gigabytes of storage but with
a price hike costing 249
what about the other model the sj 1.5
named sj 1.5 as an homage to san jose
this smartphone is comparatively cheaper
and it offers more budget specs with a 5
inch hd gorilla glass 3 display the sj
1.5 is quite good for its price because
it's powered by a mediatek
mt-6580 quad-core processor and has 16
gigabytes of internal storage the phone
also has an expandable memory so the
customers can look forward to that too
furthermore there is an option for dual
sim slots sj 1.5 has a nice pixel
display of 720x1280 and to be honest sj
1.5 is more eye-catching due to its
striking look with a flat top and a
round bottom with rubber detailing it's
easier to handle and looks incredibly
cool too another thing that makes these
phones special is that they've been
designed by the high-powered san
francisco firm called ammunition so both
phones have a sleek look to die for
which can be chalked up to ammunition
and the slightly extruded 5-inch screens
not only look very classy but also offer
protection from dropping according to
scully these phones have better
components and specs than what their
target market is used to he says our
differentiation is no compromise
beautiful design we said the only way
we'll go into this business is if we're
convinced we can build products with no
compromise they have to not just look
cool but be perfect in terms of fit and
finish this guy single-handedly boosted
the sales of apple and is considered to
be one of the biggest names in the world
of business entrepreneurship and
investment he also introduced the ob
world phone in 2014 and made a strong
entry into the market by now there are
four models introduced by the silicon
valley smartphone manufacturer and one
of the models the sf1 was voted the
fifth best smartphone in vietnam
scully's history with apple
not many people know that john scully
was practically the god of marketing in
the early 1970s due to his ingenuity and
proficiency scully made pepsico a
worldwide success so when steve jobs got
wind of it he offered scully a job at
apple but at the time apple wasn't
exactly the cash cow it is now naturally
scully politely refused but steve jobs
was determined to take scully in because
of his soaring success in the marketing
industry scully mentions in an interview
how steve jobs convinced him he says and
jobs looked me in the eye and said do
you want to sell sugary drinks for the
rest of your life or do you want to join
me in changing the world scully further
mentions i could not say no to him
because if i did that i would have kept
wondering for the rest of my life what
would have happened if i had worked with
jobs and helped him in changing the
world he joined apple in the early 1980s
and spent the next two decades mass
marketing macintosh personal computers
when he signed at apple he got a million
dollar signing bonus a million dollars
in annual pay and power over 350 000
shares of apple in fact with his
reliable temperament and decent
reputation as a marketing guru he was
selected to be the ceo of apple rather
than the great steve jobs himself who
severely lacked the discipline and
temperament needed to run a company as
big as apple and so to this day scully
is considered one of the most successful
entrepreneurs and investors in high-tech
startups my job was
turn the apple ii around and get it
generating as much cash as possible
which we did very successfully
however scully left apple four years
after joining because of his fallout
with steve jobs as well as the
tremendous pressure of the job after
increasing the sales of the company from
982 million dollars to 7 billion during
his tenure john scully finally stepped
down and mentioned how there is only so
much that a single person can do but
it's the fallout between scully and jobs
that really soured things to the point
of no return at the time jobs was
heading the macintosh team that had its
own marketing team whereas scully had
close to no control over the macintosh
division moreover jobs was often too
spontaneous and unreliable after
multiple power clashes and heated
arguments things came to a head when
john scully called the meeting of the
board of directors and presented the
entire situation in front of them this
ended up with steve jobs losing his
position as the general manager of the
macintosh project and him resigning from
apple overall in 1985 but the story
doesn't end here after a long time john
scully has created his own flagship
smartphone and we couldn't be more eager
to check it out scully's intentions with
his smartphone company since scully had
spent a lot of time in india africa the
middle east and several parts of asia
and had traveled the world a lot he
noticed the emerging market in these
countries and how the competition there
was not as tough as the western market
according to john scully when he was
asked the question of whether they were
making their own iphone with a twist he
replied we are really inspired by the
tremendous success that apple has had
with the iphone but apple is not really
a competitor to us i brought together
the head of apple's product design
robert brunner who had hired johnny ive
and this week our team worked on
preparing smartphones that were a lot
cheaper than an iphone and to help our
marketing team we presented our product
in emerging markets he mentioned that he
will not be taking his business to a
market where there is exceptionally high
growth and tough competition and where
he has to take business away from a
competitor after all it's not easy to
compete with chinese companies that are
dominating the market for god knows how
long also let's remember the fact that
john scully's phone company isn't
exactly public it is a private company
so every move needs to be calculated
because the budget might not allow it
but that's not to say that scully isn't
ambitious and motivated despite not
being young and nimble anymore he
expresses his hopes in these words it
would be a lot harder if you asked me to
fix htc i wouldn't have a clue but if
you look at a clean sheet of paper it's
amazing how interesting it can be if you
like the video make sure to hit the like
and subscribe button to make sure that
you don't miss any future updates don't
forget to turn on the post notifications